are you know mm-hmm Devon well hold on I
wasn't expecting to get asked that I'm
like no no no no hell no that is a
multi-layered question
[Laughter]
he seemed way too excited to want to
explain that that is a multi-layered
question okay the first layer is just a
bit of like white privilege whipped
cream okay you sprinkle a little bit of
you know whiteness on the top and then
the second layer okay this is where we
have a white guilt this is a delicious
layer when you sink your teeth into that
one
whoa your sweet tooth gonna go on fire
then you got the third layer this is
where the other minorities lie and they
pretend there's kneeling as bad as there
the black people but they're not and
then you've got your fourth layer this
is where the gaze resides and I'm kind
of in there because I'm gay but I'm
black so I'm on the other layer layer
okay this way you really want to get a
little bit of a see stuff cuz we left a
party do you like to party okay Rossi's
of course this is the best layer it's
the fifth layer okay this is where the
base of the cake happens hey this is
where you get in and you sink your teeth
and you're like what's that [ __ ] right
and so you're here and just like oh my
god okay this is where there's like the
least amount of privilege cuz it's
supporting the rest of society but it
doesn't even get seen do you know what
I'm saying yeah how do you like them
layers okay huh so to answer your
question am i Rossi's of course not okay
no no not even a little bit I wouldn't
say that summery nor I'm capable of it
didn't anyone tell you black people
cannot be read if they say there's both
about institutions because we don't own
enough power and so therefore if we
don't own enough power we can't be if
they say that yeah listen if this Cisco
lookin [ __ ] is gonna be mad he is
gonna say it'd be mad right now
he's about to say it you're about to say
it be mad right now
but people can't be racist and why is
racism is it
to tional eyes thing I called it of
course he was how could you not think
you would say that I suspect this is
just really part of a basically a
movement to absolve all black people of
any responsibility when it comes to
certain actions that they may take by
saying that we can never be this then
you can't accuse me of that problem is
it's not it's it's not real
it's faulty it's faulty thinking the
equivalent of saying women can't be
sexist because the fact that men hold
more power in society that's ridiculous
Frank
yes that's nonsensical thank you right
there is such a thing as institutional
racism but there's also something as
interpersonal right there's not like
it's not just institutional sexism you
can have sexism on a person-to-person
basis does that make sense when I hear
this kind of stuff it frustrates me
because so intellectually dishonest it's
so many black people bought into it
because one it absolves them of
responsibility of their actions and I'm
just saying it's easy why would you
bring this to the conversation it's so
useless and also think sometimes people
get so focused on a North American
context they don't realize that black
people have engaged in ethnic cleansing
of other black people look at Wanda for
example when one group did what they did
to another group and yes there was a bit
of outside influence but it doesn't
change the fact that they engage in that
behavior and it happens in a lot of
other African countries without any
outside involvement as well and it's not
just an institutional thing like if a
white person a random white dude commits
a hate crime against a black person you
wouldn't say well he's part of
institutions no he said he's created
hate crime that was racist well if a
black person does something to someone
else on the basis of their race then
they're engaging in that very same thing
has nothing to do with institutions not
everything is happening with some
institution behind it sometimes this
interpersonal stuff right when you go to
the corner store that Chinese guy tells
you whatever he says and he follows you
around the store that's not the
institution that's just a
person-to-person thing we often make the
Ignace fake of whenever we think about
racism we only think about white people
doing racism we don't think what happens
with Latinos and blacks what happened
with Latinos can't be racist because
they don't have the nutritional power
what do you mean what do you mean they
can't be Rossi's they don't
institutional power we don't talk what
do they have Puerto Rico who cares and
also doesn't anything to the
conversation you don't in line
everything it's not because one group
can potentially be more effective at it
than it doesn't mean that the same
person can't engage in that same thing
the same way just because a man can
engage in more effective forms of
violence against women doesn't mean that
women can't be violent towards men it
has nothing to do with that domestic
violence it's still happening we don't
have the institution I hate that stuff
man it's get everyone heard that same
and you know you know that Dyson guy the
guy whose name was like a vacuum the guy
who's the doctor yeah who talks like
he's a poet but he's really cringey yeah
okay him he's been pandering that stuff
forever for those of you who have heard
similar viewpoints as files by similar
people let me tell you this that kind of
lethal ignorance that kind of viewpoint
that disparages black people number one
that kinda sentence and talks down to us
number two that draws specious spurious
parallels between white racism and black
racism racism presupposes the ability to
control a significant segment of the
population economically politically and
socially by imposing law covenant and
restriction on their lives black people
ain't had no capacity to do that can we
be bigoted yes can we be prejudiced yes
racists know the unintelligence of the
formulation is problematic when any
black person says it it is illogical and
irrational to its core what we see when
we hear these kinds of comments are
lethal self hatred the denial of the
humanity to black people that we see
reflected in the dominant white society
refracted through the prism of our own
black lives unless it by enlightenment
such people are peripatetic that is
walking around virtuous not in terms of
their virtue but virtue was virtual
expressions of degraded self hatred I
feel sorry I feel horrible when I'm in
the presence of such mean speaking
ignorance spewing
incredibly cantankerous viewpoints that
don't honor the end
the beauty the diversity of the
complexity and the wondrous rapturous
intelligence of black people that's why
I hang with black folk all the time
because I know better than that
you heard
that is a multi-layered question yeah I
see my neighbor was like man this man so
smart I'm like yo all the sophistry it's
not as intelligent as you think it is
but because he speaks like a pastor and
he says this stuff people eat that up
confidence will get you a long way you
can recognize the power of instances I
can recognize its existence and still
knowledge the fact that not all happens
on an institutional level there are
different layers there are different
categories I think I can be prejudiced
but I'm not racist I'm prejudiced I feel
like I'm biased when it comes to white
people honestly I feel like you guys all
watch the same TV show I swear to God I
feel like everybody saw the same
Breakfast Club interview ruff there's
some codes there's some codes not to be
a racist not to sound like mother
there's the key words we give so much
farther than words that we make them
avoid the words so they avoid it so they
have the same speech because they know
how to navigate this issue without
sounding like such-and-such I'm not
racist but I have you know prejudice
like I mean potatoes potato cuz I don't
tend to give them the benefit of the
doubt because they come into this world
there's so much privilege and why have
you come into this world with so much
privilege they do everybody got their
privilege I was talking someone of my
friend white girl saying yeah well you
know you had more privileges than me
talking about me right and I was like
yeah I didn't like everybody got at some
point aside of privilege you know what I
mean I grew up with more privilege in a
lot of my white friends a lot of most of
the world most of the world you know and
I understand that but then again I told
her you're right
growing up I had a lot more privileges
to parents stay together and still is
cool good fight good look good finances
everything is that they're smart with
their money but if I was this sheet next
to you police come they're gonna ask you
with you I yeah because you walking
beside me so at the another day yes we
all have our privileges women have
privileges man have privileges
there's some privileges in being a black
man there's some privileges in being a
white woman everybody at some point got
their own privilege
don't mind people acknowledging the fact
that there are certain privileges to
whiteness I think whenever comes to this
discussion I just think it's so limited
in regards to the privileges that were
accounting for hmm do we talk about
financial pillage do we talk about
beauty privilege do we talk about where
you were born privilege what passport
you were born pearl it's like you know
this pretty much thing is such a
multi-layered
[Music]
I do that through yes boys one more time
[ __ ] I might start no you might [ __ ]
what [ __ ] don't talk to me like that
you know these comets gonna be I knew
these [ __ ] were couple I knew it
that's your father be cognizant of that
and be also cognizant that whatever
judgments you may come of a white person
you come across be like they're
privileged you don't know in which ways
they were disadvantaged on other axis
right well let's get into it I say the
n-word when I by myself and listening to
rap songs I've seen a black man like
walking towards me and I cross the
street but I'm always in my head like
please know that this is because you're
a man not because you're black that's
why I love this point when I go to the
grocery stores my face has not been this
relaxed yeah for a long time like a mean
mug on the world let's just like they're
scared but I don't blame me not Rossi's
I know it's because of if I cuff on them
you know I don't have to have a nice
smile everybody's stressed anyways yeah
so it's good I haven't been this relaxed
mmm like ever right so basically you're
you're saying like when you walk the
streets you don't mind looking like a
thug no I don't write no people are
going around me cuz I'm not gay that's
right me not me it feels good to lecture
on employment chicks I'm not mad at this
girl I mean listen honestly there been
nights where I've walked home and
there's a black dude in front of me and
I cross the street so if I can do it you
could even ask cuz you don't like black
people
true true cuz I live on the fifth layer
a problem I'm not racist but I yeah yeah
you are
[Laughter]
No fed like that girl I'm not Rossi's
she's going to some heavy stereotypes so
let's let her dig her own grave I'm a
server so you know like I know races
like how do i word it without sounding
racist she's good I was about to say
that but she went there she basically
just said black people you don't tip
yeah and to be fair I mean in the States
I don't think they do but I don't know I
don't really know about that is that to
say that they don't tip that often well
it's just like saying that you know
French people don't tip here they don't
they don't I do think sometimes it is
cultural differences I don't think I'm
someone necessarily difference between
something that is racial and said
something that is racist yeah okay if
you say that a certain group of person
act a certain way but you don't put
yourself above them it's just how they
act like French they don't sit right
because in their country they don't
write I'm not better than them because I
fit I am but they don't that's what it
is I think you have to make a difference
we did something that is racial or
something right great something of this
cultural and something that is actually
you just put it you got what I'm saying
right no no I agree with that
this is never a blanket so to see all
know it's never no of course not I mean
I know I do but I never really noticed
if other people do
I definitely like stereotyped people
before I'm just like a stereotype the
stereotypes Asian people can't drive
african-american man we have something
that's bigger than everybody else that's
right you know what it is what is it you
know but do you know of course what is
it that dangling what feet you know no
just their ambition there's a writer
he was just talking about with my
friends setting her up with my other
friend I'm like but you know he's Asian
so he probably the small
why did I say that why did I think that
cuz that's what everybody says
that's everywhere that's the propaganda
that's been going on in the US whenever
they were after the war in California
there was a lot in Chinese immigrants
and stuff like that and it was trying to
get some jobs and stuff like that and
there's been a propaganda in the states
against the Chinese like they were
talking about that they bid them being
all dorky and stuff like that he puts a
lot of emphasis on that so there was a
lot there was a lot of propaganda
against Asian men it just kind of pop up
I tell myself to shut up are you racist
only what I'm driving are you racist
jokingly I tell racist jokes I'd like to
make a lot of jokes sometimes the race
jokes I do make a lot of faces jokes
when I was younger I'd like make a lot
of jokes about it but I realized like
what are these like jokes actually
saying and like what am i communicating
about people through the way I choose to
make people laugh okay they're Erykah
Badu you're a head wrap looking I don't
use anything wrong with jokes I don't
use anything wrongly raised drunks
either personally I think we should all
be able to make things here but it's not
everybody there's a comedian that goes
to that degree I understand that it is
for you that and the same as me a son
like I don't you I don't think that our
job did she make us leave gonna define
you with a whole ensemble of things it's
not just few jokes but a lot of people
that are not like that it's not because
you make a joke you're like that you
have to look at the bigger picture you
have to be able to analyze a person to
something oh yeah yeah that's not yeah
yeah I think you should be able to make
whatever jokes you want to make and you
know it's just to me a joke he's not
necessarily reflective like you said of
who you are context is very important I
assure you there's people who have some
pretty crazy acts onstage doesn't
necessarily reflect their views or
whatever they're thinking they just like
seeing absurd stuff sometimes it's fun
to say absurd stuff it's like trolling
you don't actually think the things that
you're trolling about but you do enjoy
getting a rile out of people singing
with some jokes I think anybody can be
racist
being a light-skinned person growing up
in Kenya there's
only colorism issue going on where
darker skinned people are usually looked
at differently than lighter skinned
people if you have like haters like a
certain group of people who are racist I
think my dad's the racist my father was
pretty racist had some family that are
racist
I do have relatives that are definitely
racist or Japanese also Louis is that
racist towards black people like Andy
ever challenged them or you like grandma
come on
no I let her have it I'm not even mad at
listen there's some old people she's not
gonna taste a waste
listen my mom has certain thoughts about
certain groups and I'm just like okay
what a good person but listen what are
you gonna do what can you do what can
you do you go 60 years to your life
thinking one way I'm not gonna come here
not something just the thing though you
also don't know what environment they
were raised in between those countries
and so it's hard for me to talk to you
on a level playing field when I don't
fully understand the depth of what she
went through I thought he said he was
Japanese no no okay
good are you racist no no no oh no never
no how do you know just know that you
don't hate people I feel like you know
right like if you have to tell people
that you're not racist that to me is a
great sign that you're racist are you
racist no I mean if I am please someone
tell me because that's so disappointing
are you racist I've been told I am I was
like kind of getting upset because I was
tired of hearing about your white and
Christian you're racist and you get away
with everything I was like how can you
say that yeah I'm racist because I'm a
white person I think all white people
are racist
okay I'm hoping that she's being
sarcastic
no I think she's being real you know
people like that you know how I said
like all those black people earlier
probably watched dear white people yeah
I feel like this girl watched dear white
people as well I feel like they all just
watch the same show and we all just took
their cues and like oh that's me
there's something really creepy about
like people were like yeah I see some
way it feels like they're acknowledging
it to give themselves a pat on the back
to be like I'm so progressive that I
realized the ways in which I oppress you
and I want to lighten your burdens
I know Lera but what I'd like to do is
first acknowledge me my privilege and
hopefully alleviate your struggles
you're stupid yo listen I don't know if
you're Scorpio or what not all like
listen if you are you also need to
acknowledge your privilege yeah we have
just been put into this system designed
to empower our white privilege as a
white person I am super I just want to
ask them how are you Rossi's how are you
every day like how you do I'm part of a
bigger problem where I'm just in an
institution where we just work on a
prescient black people and honestly I'm
doing what I can to dismantle my
privilege how I use my position of power
to alleviate black people and to give
them a voice because white people have
had the podium for thousands of years
and I just think it's time for other
people for women POC and the LGBT
community to take over the podium and
just air out what they need to say and
push things forward I think once we see
these people and like positions of power
I think once we do that then we can
start to see change because there's no
way that a white cisgendered male can
bring about the change that minorities
need to see the future you know like
Obama yes we can you know man I had a
girl who's talking to me like that we're
about to hook up did you say all that
[ __ ] I was like suck my please and
indeed she of course would take a job
might not take a second date but you got
to wrap this up you know better use your
white privilege girl alleviate my stress
funny so I go send me a DM I should I AB
I'm devastated and I click play and is
that point where you're like so IVA how
do you feel about dating white girls in
public and I'm like I don't
[Laughter]
girl you know that's still for me I know
a lot of people like to say yes I'm a
racist cuz that makes them feel like
people know that I'm admitting my faults
but like I think that's a weird like
cop-out
have you experienced racism oh heck yeah
you just look at her face and you like
this yes she went through some yeah it's
funny when you could look at someone's
face and just see how spirit Helen back
yeah how and back that's crazy you just
see the weight of like different events
weighing on them mm-hmm that's
interesting yeah I like that though
I like interesting faces you know I mean
you ever look at someone's face and be
like that's a story yeah that's that was
always fascinates me that you can wear
stories on your face I grew up in myself
I mean it happens every day really I've
been slammed on cop cars I've had you
know guns pulled out on me from police
officers I'm followed through a grocery
store got make fun of a lot ching-chong
linglong all this and that and you like
jump the border can you speak English
hey speak English
konichiwa I want to eat sushi from you
[Laughter]
like a bag of bees bruh I didn't expect
that at all
oh I'm sweating
usually I laugh harder than this yo they
took my breath away I just said I'm
sorry some raisin is funny some of it is
just funny it's very inappropriate is
wrong you would do that what God Gino
you know she was a bit I stopped loving
some drunk white dude just was like come
here man yeah
konichiwa can i sir sushi ah - yo hey
there Bob one I'd love to eat some jerk
chicken out of your poom poom
can I eat a roti after ba t as much as
you thought about yet stack yeah yeah
size on the football field someone have
tackled me and they were like Asians
don't play football
oh wait a second you can't say things
like that I heard a little bit but I was
like little do you know I got a little
black in me that's why I got two
touchdowns already hold on you can't
face and [ __ ] like that let me reply
with more racism you can't say that
Asians can't dominate on the football
field but I dominated because I'm part
black and what are you saying maybe I'm
trying to see things from other people's
perspective me okay just communicated
what he was trying to say is I dominate
so hard it almost seems like I got
blackened that's not what do you think I
know but I'm just made me feel little
did you know I got a little black in me
because I had two touchdowns meaning I
got that skills just saying you never
still okay let's say that fully meant
just oh that's you know what I approach
these arguments I always trying to
approach it from like what is the best
case scenario for their argument and
I'll try to dissect that and if that is
even bad yah-tchi
it's kind of like the view that we did
where it's about like a girl who's like
got mad at her
different did much better after they
were separated whatever you know yes and
people were hitting me up like Oh Abba
you know maybe it wasn't like ten years
maybe it was three years I might boo boo
I said it was like ten years that it was
bad as the best-case scenario right even
after and I still ran into her because I
was like yeah even even at ten years of
badness yo that's what you think yeah
you give them the best so that you can
argue if you can argue the best scenario
anything after that is gonna be trapped
yeah I remember being very young having
like negative perceptions of
african-american people but I've met
better people
you know myself up and I've healed I
think that just exposing myself and
being like hey like these people are
actually really cool and I shouldn't be
afraid of hanging out with them are you
racist everybody everybody can get it I
don't like nobody so I just discriminate
you I like her no she saw some at you
I'm trying to get paid no real [ __ ]
move on me to say I don't like you I
don't like you for different reasons and
I don't like you either how like I'm
even like man I don't like I think the
one girl who said just try to be
cognizant of like you're unconscious by
season just try to improve on those she
probably had my favorite answer because
I think I didn't s the best you can do
yeah where are your biases and why do
they exist and where do they come from
are they justified or unjustified and I
think from there you can start to
dismantle certain bad ideas that you may
have you know sometimes people over
there I think what I think I think yeah
but why do you think that way was that
talk to you I had a whole bunch ideas
when I was younger that I no longer have
because when I looked at them I'm like
these are bad ideas to keep in my head
they're not good things to live by
they're gonna lead me down bad roads and
make me break wrong decisions off of bad
bikes what are they based on that's what
you have to look at exactly even if it's
based upon experience is that your head
right or even that you have to reflect
oh how do you look back at how you was
acting with a kid and you always when
you tell the story you always put
yourself as the hero in the story right
sometimes you have to reflect it's like
y'all was I'm within me being a jackass
so I don't enjoy movies when
all the heroes are good for know them
and and all the bad people are bad but
it's not life that's not what it is
no I agree when I see a movie or a
theory that I'm looking at and the guy
is bad but I can identify with him with
some points you know I mean like the
Black Panther thing I'm gonna like it
more great you know what I mean are you
racist no I don't think I am I don't
think I am hmm
and I'm questioning myself all the time
so me saying that I'm not it's still
coming from a place where I still
question myself every day like or hmm
about what I do about what I even want
people give me comments and stuff like
that I still try to reflect why are they
saying that where is that Fred hmm so
let me ask you a question have you ever
done anything that was racist
sure probably okay I can't put my finger
on it yeah probably yeah I would agree
with that so then my next question I
think this is the burning question I
have at what point do summon your
actions determine whether or not you are
racist do you know I'm saying what makes
someone raises is it the fact that
they've done actions by which case you
would be racist like I would be or is
there a threshold you have to meet does
it have to plague your whole worldview
was a mix of a lot of things not just
one thing it's I mean the impact what
did you really mean if that thing is
recurring there's a lot of things that
got to go through that there's a guy i
remember when i was like backing into
this dude at some point call me some
name i'm like yo that's dope what did
you say you said it again whatever is
that person that person came back to me
like yo I'm sorry about that like yo
whatever you could be sorry but I don't
forget six months down the line I see
them doing that [ __ ] again
mm-hmm but you haven't learned anything
from anything you're doing the same
behavior right and resort to that you
have to check yourself that will make me
believe that that person's a razor
because whenever you are in that same
disposition that's your go-to place okay
so there's you know how often do you do
that thing
how seriously about it of course a
context of all of that but a bit of a
lot of factors it's not just one thing
it's not just one there's a lot of
layers mmm well you know sometimes you
say this person's racist and I'm like
how do you feel comfortable saying that
I don't know man
you're not saying I don't have to
explain that I think I'm pretty
reluctant to call someone races unless
I'm like really sure but even that I'm
not sure how I'm sure so that's why I
was just questioning it's like just one
that lady when you weather the show you
know and she was saying while you were
on stage that I've got fun
yeah exactly but you can't explain it
how did she had and she at would exhibit
this show you would still have a feeling
that you know what I would feel like I
ladies races but it's not gonna firm
like a dunking firm right so I wouldn't
call her that
mm-hmm put it just be some [ __ ] I
wouldn't call it that either you're
right you're right you're right you're
right because every time I call someone
a racist like people are quick to
question you all right okay but what was
it what did you do what did they do I
get you like they try to gauge your
threshold of racism so when you call
someone racist people are gonna question
it right that's when you're in an
environment of people that are not used
to deal with racism I agree okay cool
well listen we want to pass that
question on - you guys are you guys
racist and if so how do you guys deal
with that and also what do you think
about the question I posed to preach how
do you determine if someone is or is it
we want to know your answer so leave it
in the comments below if we or
[Laughter]
[Music]
you